get inspired you have to find ways to
stay inspired and motivated with your
business because otherwise nobody's
going to do this thing for you and I
know some days it's hard to get out of
bed and go to work you may have had a
really bad week but this is on you to
make it happen and you need to create an
environment that motivates and inspires
you think about the people you surround
yourself with the resources the
information the things that you surround
yourself with the environment you've
created for yourself and does it build
you up or tear you down here's a quick
example I try as much as possible to
surround myself with people things
activities that inspire me I recently
went to go watch the jobs movie and life
about Steve Jobs great movie I saw it
twice with two different friends of mine
and both times I came away inspired
empowered ready to take action ready to
do something to grow my business and it
gave me new ways of thinking about what
I was doing if you haven't checked out
the movie go check it out I think you'll
like it but the point here is you have
to surround yourself with these kinds of
things so think about how you're
spending your time if you're going to go
out and watch them entertainment you
going to go out to a movie are you
watching movies like jobs and may give
you some ideas or you're out you know
sitting in front of your TV watching
garbage do you spend your time your
leisure activities are you reading
helpful information books that build you
up books on great entrepreneurs who've
done great things that inspire you
motivate you to want to be a better
person or you reading trash or not
reading at all think about the people
you surround yourself with are the
people in your life people who accept
what you do who love what you do who
motivate you who give you ideas who
inspire you to be better or they
question what you're doing tearing you
down finding holes in your plants as an
entrepreneur you have the ability to
design your own life you're your own
boss where you work who you work with
what you're working on is totally within
your control so create an environment
that supports you that builds you up
that lifts you
that inspires you every day try to do
something that gets you excited
hopefully the work itself that you're
doing you know if you're following your
passion you're helping people hopefully
that inspires you to but it's hard
running the business socks it's one of
the hardest things you're ever going to
do in your life and you need to create
that supportive environment to get you
through to make sure you go to work
today to make sure you give it your all
you don't leave anything on the table so
think about the things in your life the
people the resources the activities
you're doing I know they toxic for you
are they tearing you down or they
building you up inspiring you motivating
you to do the best entrepreneur can be
believed if you like this video please
give it a thumbs up below it makes want
to do more for you and I'd love to hear
you have to think if you leave a comment
under the video I really appreciate
seeing those come in it makes my morning
every day so thank you guys and I'll see
you soon